from colleagues on the Senate floor
[Music]
this week on Q&A Yale University Law
School professor Amy Chua professor Chua
discusses her book political tribes
group instinct and the fate of Nations
[Music]
Amy Chua author of political tribes
group instinct in the fate of Nations
what can we learn from your analysis of
Venezuela and Hugo Chavez well you might
think of Venezuela as being almost the
opposite of the United States but it's
actually pretty striking the parallels
between Chavez and President Donald
Trump and the rise of both men
so back in 1998 a little-known man by
the name of Hugo Chavez swept to power
in Venezuela to the horror of the elites
they were horrified he was a former
ex-con paratrooper no political
experience spoke very lackadaisically
said crazy things for example that maybe
capitalism had killed life on Mars and
yet he swept to power and the elites
very much like the elites in this
country were completely stunt taken
aback unprepared so how did that happen
here's the analysis in Venezuela for
hundreds of years the economy and
actually the the politics had been
controlled by a very small kind of
European blooded lighter-skinned
elite who controlled the oil wealth
which is vast in Venezuela they also
controlled the media and below that most
of the majority of the people in
Venezuela actually didn't look like
those people they were darker skinned
had more Indian blood a lot of African
ancestry because Venezuela had slaves
but yet those people weren't had no
access to the wealth then they were
completely shut out of politics so for
you
years this went on and suddenly because
of democracy when Hugo Chavez came in he
sort of played the race card
he actually said whereas being darker
skinned and Indian blooded was something
bad before he actually said look I look
like you I'm poor like you I speak like
you these arrogant snobby people they
don't care about you and people voted
him in and that is very similar now he
is not he's actually our president
Donald Trump is not the first of
America's first world leader to have had
a reality TV show Hugo Chavez's and he
actually had a reality TV show while he
was president he would go to a building
because he was as big socialist he
nationalized everything and with
everybody watching he would point to a
certain building and say expropriate it
in Spanish and people loved it so
flipping to the United States it's
actually quite similar except for the
obvious which is Donald Trump space is
exactly the opposite it's largely white
and Donald Trump is also not a socialist
he is a billionaire but you still have
the exact same populist dynamic that is
you have a group of people that are
viewed I guess you might call them
coastal elites I mean they're not all
coastal you know they they live in
cities but and they're not all wealthy
but there are professors and journalists
and bankers and lawyers who control or
seen as controlling the levers of power
Washington Silicon Valley Hollywood and
they're very multicultural and sort of
liberal usually not always and very
politically correct and very
cosmopolitan and you have all these
people in the heartland in the South in
working-class white communities
blue-collar communities where I felt
shut out and looked down and excluded
you're you're racist you're not speaking
the right way you're sexist you just
have felt powerless and somehow Donald
Trump was able to
tap into those people and it wasn't just
economics it was really the way they
related to him culturally he spoke like
they do you know kind of casually always
getting in trouble but they didn't mind
that they always got in trouble gorged
himself on McDonald's worldwide
wrestling so that's the parallel a very
charismatic demagogic politician who
actually targeted the outside that is
that he said these people are exploiting
you they're controlling everything let's
let's take America back for you the real
people who own it and that's exactly the
message that shabbos said let me ask you
if there's a parallel here that and on
page 135 you say in that chapter on
Venezuela today Venezuela is practically
a failed state yes so Venezuela is a
country that had a market dominant
minority this is again a small minority
that controlled vastly disproportionate
wealth in these countries democracy can
often be very destabilizing because you
have this powerful minority that wants
to cling to its power and then you have
much larger poor often less educated
frustrated majority and what I say in
the book and explain is in this clash of
the poorer numbers and the wealthier
minority the results are often deadly
because people will fight as I say
sometimes to the death of the country
sometimes you'll see lurches towards
authoritarianism and you know you're
seeing a lot of that now you see
typically an erosion of trust in our
institutions I hate to say it but this
is something that we are talking about a
lot in the United States you know these
institutions that used to be so revered
are now we don't trust them we don't
trust electoral outcomes and this is
critically important it's what's made us
special
unlike developing countries we always
respect our elections as much as we hate
the result we don't have a coup we don't
overturn it so there are some signs now
that we need to be careful we need to
get back to who we are but
for the first time in our history we are
starting to have some dynamics that were
historically more associated with
developing countries in your book you
talk about Vietnam Iraq and Afghanistan
and I want to show you a clip of some
video of John Foster Dulles who used to
be secretary of state in the United
States this goes way back to 1954 and
have you comment on this I saw
everywhere that there were people who
were frightened and worried at the
evidence either were there in their own
country or in very close proximity to it
of aggressive Chinese Communists
intentions it would seem as though it
was quite possible that the Chinese
Communists are not content to stop until
it is apparent that they are stopped by
superior is it what's your reaction when
you hear that from 1954 well my reaction
is really the thesis of the book which
is that the United States has been we
tend to think of our foreign policy in
terms of great ideological divides
capitalism versus communism for example
as in the Vietnam War and what we miss
is we fail to see the importance of the
group identities that are actually
matter most to people on the ground so
in Vietnam the United States missed two
things and it's really the ethnic
dimension by now I think most Americans
realize that we missed the role of
nationalism that in a way with the
Vietnamese people were fighting for was
their freedom their sovereignty and you
know communism was in there but that was
just a almost secondary to how much they
wanted their freedom but here's
something that most Americans even
experts still don't know today there was
an ethnic angle the United States made a
terrible mistake
assuming that Vietnam was just a pond of
communist China they just thought you
know what the Chinese are gonna take
over the Vietnamese are right there what
they didn't realize is that Vietnam
and China are mortal enemies China
colonized Vietnam for a thousand years
every myth of the Vietnamese people
every hero is always fighting the big
Chinese enemy and remember Vietnam is
tiny
China is huge it's like a giant
500-pound genie which is China sitting
on the equivalent of a little lamp which
is Vietnam so the idea that we that we
missed the history if we had looked at
the history of long-standing suspicion
and distrust we might have realized that
Vietnam was not the pond of China more
importantly we missed an inside element
- inside Vietnam Vietnam had what I call
a market dominant minority that is
historically they had a tiny ethnic
Chinese minority and the Chinese are
different from the Vietnamese - a lot of
us Americans that uh same thing not the
same thing for them the Chinese minority
came from when they originally colonized
the country but there were only about 1%
of the population
think about that 1% is tiny and yet
historically they controlled about 70 to
80 percent of the private economy all
the commerce all the financing all the
middlemen networking and when the French
colonizers came in they made the Chinese
richer they dealt with that little
Chinese minority so the point here is
that the capitalists in Vietnam were not
even the Vietnamese people they were all
part of this hated outsider group it
would be like in America if all the only
rich people belonged to they were all
from you know another country pick a
country China Lebanon and there were no
up you know ordinary Americans were rich
that's how they felt so here we come in
the United States saying we're promoting
capitalism and we completely miss the
idea that these Vietnamese people are
seeing that we're promoting policies
that only help this Chinese minority
when we came in they serviced our troops
they did all the financing the black
market the prostitutes they got richer
and richer the
jeans that we put in reviewed us in
cahoots with these corrupt Chinese
businessmen the Chinese were also it
wasn't just that they were wealthy they
stuck with their own they were insular
they intermarried with their own they
spoke their own language and they didn't
even fight in the war they dodged the
draft so from the point of view of the
Vietnamese America we thought we were
fighting for freedom we couldn't
understand why the Vietnamese wouldn't
support us and that's because we missed
the most important group dynamics that
were operating
it wasn't about communism versus
capitalism what the Vietnamese saw is oh
these Americans want to help this tiny
little group of greedy outsiders there's
nothing in it from us and they're
bombing our houses everybody we know is
dying our sons and husbands are dying so
no wonder we didn't get that support the
war was over in 73 we pulled out in 75
20 years later in 1995 here is the
former Secretary of Defense talking
about the very thing that you're you're
bringing up we totally misjudged the
threat we believed that Vietnam as
Eisenhower said in 1954 was a domino and
if the Soviets and the Chinese
controlled it the rest of Southeast Asia
would fall Cambodia Laos Malaysia and
Thailand Indochina and that and maybe
India and that the Communist strength
would be so increased that the that
Western Europe would be in danger now
that's what we thought we were totally
wrong how could we have missed this
first of all I gave him so much credit
for acknowledging that and the answer
actually lies in both the best of
America and the worst of America part of
the reason that we're so blind to these
ethnic divides and tribal divides is
because we have had such exceptional
success in our own country and it's
really true we are special you know the
idea is if Germans and poles and
Hungarians and chews and Japanese could
all become America
within just one or two generations you
know why can't Sunnis and Shias and
Kurds all become Iraqis and oh these
people in Vietnam if we just put in
freedom they'll come together you know
who cares this little distinction
between the Vietnamese and the Chinese
that's America at its best contributing
to our inability to see these you know
kind of smaller more primal identities
and another more negative side I hate
this term because it's overused but part
of it is this legacy of racism I think
for a lot of Americans they couldn't see
the difference between the Vietnamese
and the Chinese because they all looked
alike you know there are some quotes no
they're all gooks and slants and that's
just something that we're all getting
better at and you know I mean to be fair
there weren't very many Asians in this
country back then so they didn't know
the difference but but part of it is
that we just didn't study the history of
these countries we didn't know how deep
those divides were and they just all
kind of looked oriental to us to catch
up quickly from the last interview em
seniors since 2002 your parents were
born in China moved to the Philippines
moved to the United States you were born
in Champaign Illinois spent some time in
Indiana and then went to Harvard yes I
went to Harvard
and you got your law degree so Harvard
law and how long have you been teaching
at Yale Law School Oh since 2002 right
about the time that my first book world
on fire came and when we first met our
world has changed so much since 2002 and
here's another example this is from 2003
and you write about this in your book
it's former president george w bush
there was a time when many said that the
cultures of japan and germany were
incapable of state sustaining democratic
values well they were wrong
some say the same of iraq today they are
mistaken so well he was right about
germany and japan but here's the problem
they were the wrong models for Iraq
Germany and Japan
after the Second World War were about as
ethnically homogeneous as you could get
I mean Japan has always been homogeneous
almost 97% just ethnic Japanese and
Germany because of the Holocaust was
also ethnically homogeneous so it was a
bad comparison the better comparison
actually for Iraq sadly is the former
Yugoslavia like the former Yugoslavia
Iraq when we went in was a deeply
divided country there was the schism
between the Shias and the Sunnis but
also the Kurds and all of this had been
bottled up kind of held in check by
Saddam Hussein who just compressed
everything and Iraq like Venezuela like
Vietnam also had a market dominant
minority the roughly 15% Sunnis so the
Sunnis are the same group that Saddam
Hussein belonged to they had controlled
that country politically economically
militarily for hundreds of years first
under the Ottomans then under the
British who favored that Sunni minority
ruling through them indirectly and then
most egregiously under Saddam Hussein
who favored the Sunnis and not just that
it wasn't just that he allowed the
Sunnis to get wealthy control the wealth
he persecuted the Kurds and the Shia
majority so once again you have the same
dynamic a long dominant hated minority
in this case it's the Sunnis a different
sect and then suddenly we're our idea we
come in the United States and we think
democracy is the panacea we don't pay
any attention to the tribal divisions
the Sunnis or she is we just think if we
just have elections we're going to
produce a wonderful free-market
democracy nothing like that happened
instead what happened is exactly what
you would predict when you suddenly give
majority rule to a country where the
majority was so long suppressed the
Shias whom we empowered immediately use
their votes to revenge to take revenge
on the Sunnis understand
who had persecuted them from so long
there was suddenly the rising of
demagogues fundamentalist leaders who
said we have to kill them we need to pay
back time if the anti us and in the end
the Sunnis all didn't want democracy
because they saw their numbers were so
small so they resisted and they went
into al-qaeda they went into what is now
Isis they didn't want democracy because
they saw it in the cards and that she is
just implemented only pro sHIIP policies
and so the result is not as we hoped
that our invasion would produce this
beacon of stability in the Middle East
instead we produced a situation where
the country soon dissolved into really
the brink of Civil War and it was like
that for years and years and years and
we then produced Isis which I don't know
of Americans realize is a Sunni movement
now it's not just a fundamentalist
movement that wants to unite a lot of
Islamists and fight the United States
they also want to exterminate the Shias
before Iraq in 2003 March was invasion
was Afghanistan in 2001 and here is big
news Brzezinski who was Jimmy Carter's
national security adviser in 1979 the we
know of their deep belief in God we are
confident that their struggle will
succeed the regiment of what I stopped
it also homo Salman Anya that land over
there is yours you'll go back to it one
day because your fight will prevail and
you'll have your homes and your mosques
back again because your cause is right
and God is on your side talking to
Mujahideen but right next to him was
Warren Christopher who went on to be the
Secretary of State so once again we see
the same pattern which is we had the
best of intentions we were we thought we
were fighting communism but once again
we thought in terms of these grand
principles and we were blind to the
actual
group dynamics that mattered we actually
armed the Taliban we it was our dollars
our guns our weapons that gave rise to
the Taliban we thought that we were
dealing with freedom fighters who were
going to help our side but we didn't
realize that we were getting played by
Pakistan which is very Punjabi dominated
and they wanted to radicalize the
Pashtun the passions are the largest
ethnic group in Afghanistan we missed
all of this we didn't know what Pashtuns
and Punjabis and Taj explored there were
nobody in the state government that even
spoke those languages we were just
thinking about the Cold War and because
of this we allowed Pakistan to play us
it gave rise to the Taliban but what's
interesting is even fast-forwarding to
today right after 9/11 we sent troops in
and we made the same mistake now we had
a different lens we weren't thinking
about the Cold War anymore now we were
thinking about the fight against
terrorism but we switched ideological
lenses we just divided the world and
it's a terrorists and you know democracy
lovers the United States what we missed
is that the Taliban is not just a
fundamentalist religious movement it is
that but it is also an ethnic movement
so to back up a little but Afghanistan
is full of different ethnic groups and
the biggest four include the Pashtuns
the Tajiks the Uzbek the Hazaras
and the Pashtuns were the ones that
founded Afghanistan and they dominated
the country for hundreds of years they
were always dominant in fact some people
think that Afghan and Pashtun are
synonyms but right around 9/11 and just
before the passions were fearing that
their power was diminishing but they
were declining they were under threat
from the rival groups we missed it all
we saw everything only against this axis
of evil we didn't know about these
Tajikistan Uzbekistan when we invaded we
allied ourselves with the postulants
Vegas
most hated enemies the Uzbek and the Taj
--ax we were viewed as favoring them we
set up a government and we put them in
key positions not realizing that this
was shooting ourselves in the foot that
we were never going to get you know a
majority of the Afghan people on our
side if it looked like we were favoring
the other ethnic groups so we miss that
and that's why we're still there we've
spent so much so many lives loss and
even now now there are several books
many excellent books called the Pashtun
problem the Pashtun dilemma
unfortunately it's about 15 years too
late that we're now just realizing this
you did something in the book I've never
personally I've never seen before and
that is use Toto's told us where the
name Pakistan came from P stands for
Punjab a for Afghan referring to
Pashtuns and let's see what else Kate
for Kashmir s for Sen and tan for
Baluchistan yes and that just shows
again that Pakistan we think of as a
country or maybe you know a sort of
Islamist country was which it is but
Pakistan is made of all these different
ethnic tribes and each letter in the
word Pakistan represents one of those
tribes and the P stands for the most
powerful militarily the Punjabis and
it's actually the eighth that stands for
the postions so right there in the name
we should have studied this are these
deep ethnic identities that matters so
much to people in that region that we
were completely oblivious of Venezuela
Vietnam Iraq and Afghanistan just a part
of your book there's a lot more about
the United States and here is just about
a year ago
JD Vance who very successful book called
hillbilly elegy was here let's listen to
what he had to say what happened is that
I had a professor her name was Amy Chua
and she is an author of a couple of
pretty famous books and she said you
know JD this is a really interesting
story you're making some really
interesting arguments you should think
about publishing a book I said I
whatever I'll think about it right I'll
just write it and just not worry about
whether
ever gonna get published and a few
months later I was still in law school
she connected me with some friends of
hers in the publishing industry and one
thing led to another
excuse me and I had a book deal
why did you recognize his story as being
significant well I'm so proud of him you
know it's funny superficially it looks
like we have nothing in common
I'm a daughter of Chinese immigrants my
parents were graduate students he's from
a poor Appalachian family his mother was
an addict but actually we have a lot in
common
we're both from the Midwest were both we
were sort of outsiders I grew up very
not exactly poor but we only went to a
restaurant once a year my dad wore the
same pair of shoes for eight years
they were very very thrifty immigrants
without much and we were JD and I were
always Outsiders never part of the elite
we talked about those eat all you can
buffets but I recognized something in
him something honest and pure and he was
very interested I guess in group
identities like I am because he was from
this I guess what some people call
Hillbillies or white trash and he
understood that community and loved that
community and that's a community that
has paid a huge made a huge impact in in
the 2016 election how have you gotten to
know the United States
how have I gotten to know it yeah living
here loving the country I mean if you
traveled a lot is it reading of wits I
well first of all I grew up seven years
in the Midwest and then I my father
moved to Berkeley so I grew up I spent
seven years in high school there so I
saw a totally different part of the
world it really feels like a different
planet Indiana and California and then I
moved to the East Coast where I went to
school so but even somebody like me I
still don't know all of America I mean I
I don't you know I don't claim to be an
expert on on parts of Appalachia I
learned that from actually reading JD's
book and talking to him when he was my
student I said oh my gosh I had no idea
there was this much poverty and
frustration and exclude
and that's another reason I thought he
had to write the book there was such a
you know we tend to think of minorities
being disadvantaged but there are almost
fewer poor working white working-class
whites at a place like Yale Law School
than there are minorities actually you
point out there are 75 million people in
the United States that follow NASCAR
what does that mean
well it means that America is very
divided right now and I think there's
mutual snob ISM and arrogance on both
sides and we really need to remember
what makes us Americans so right now
there is a big divide it's not just
black and white
it's really not people focus on this but
actually America's white majority is now
divided loosely speaking there are what
you might call coastal elites I mean
they're not all coastal they also live
in the cities and they're not all
wealthy but they tend to be very
multicultural and progressive and
cosmopolitan they've traveled around the
world maybe more than they've traveled
in the United States and they tend to
not really know the people in the middle
of the country they tend to have a
little bit of an arrogant attitude about
NASCAR
you know these flag-waving bumpkins they
tend to use very harsh language I think
without really knowing people as people
like they're oh they're all racist or
sexist because they don't talk in this
kind of politically correct way that you
know if you're on college campus you
learn how to speak there's always a new
vocabulary it's changing all the time
how can people how can ordinary
Americans possibly know what the right
word is to use but if you say the wrong
thing oh my gosh you're xenophobic
you're racist you're a misogynist you're
you know you're anti Islam and so
there's this great distrust and it runs
in both directions
there's nobody blameless we have to all
elevate ourselves that a lot of the
people in the middle of the country they
think of these coastal whites as being
so Pro minority why do they like
immigrants so much why are they always
trying to help the poor in Africa so
they you see dialog like they don't love
Americans they just want to help all
these foreigners well that's bad - who
are real Americans we're all real
Americans this is what's so special
about America is that we are what I call
in the book we are a super group
we are alone among the major powers the
United Kingdom is not France is not and
I defend this China recent China to
China's absolutely not let me do a super
group is a country that has two
characteristics the first is a very
strong overarching national identity so
we are Americans it's very strong but
the second requirement for a super group
is it has to be a country where
individual subgroup identities are
allowed to flourish so that you can be
Irish American Libyan American Croatian
American Japanese American you know I'm
you know Chinese American and yet
intensely patriotic at the same time
that is so rare so you mentioned China
China has one but not the other it's got
this really strong overarching Chinese
identity but it doesn't let its
individual minorities flourish the we
girls and the Tibetans their cultures
are very much suppressed yeah you can't
even wear you know speak these languages
France is the same thing a very strong
French identity but they're having a lot
of problems with their Muslim
communities because there was the
burqini ban they can't wear headscarves
they Kendall they one of the leaders
actually said you speak and eat and talk
and dress like the French or you can't
live in this country so we're special
and I think we all need to get back to
that without saying that half of the
country who voted for the other side
they're not the real Americans we have
to realize that you know our national
identity is capacious enough it's built
in to more Constitution we have a
special Constitution where our national
identity is not defined by any ethnic
subgroup it doesn't belong just to the
Irish Americans or the you know German
Americans it's ethnically
and religiously neutral you need to get
back to that I want to show some video
of a young woman who's in her mid-20s at
most names Tammy Lauren and I want to
ask you why you cited this in your book
this has been seen by 66 million people
at a minimum Colin I support the First
Amendment I support your right to
freedom of speech and expression go for
it bud it's this country the country
that you have so much disdain for that
allows you the right to speak your mind
it protects your right to the a whiny
indulgent attention-seeking crybaby it
also protects my right to shred you for
it see the national anthem in our flag
they are not symbols of black America
white America brown America or purple
America for that matter there are
patriots of every race that have fought
and died for this country and we honor
the flag and sing the anthem as a
reminder well she's a very charismatic
and they're parts of what she says that
I think are right we we are a ethnically
neutral country that's the best of
America the thing about that clip that's
dangerous is that without her realizing
it
she is also sort of doing it us versus
them she is kind of tapping into these
fears that a lot of people legitimately
have in parts of the country where
they're they they're used to America
being a country that for 200 years was
economically and politically and
culturally dominated by really European
whites that's just a fact and right now
with a Browning of America where whites
are on the verge of losing their
majority status as I explained in the
book probably by 2040 for whites may no
longer be a majority and that is a very
anxiety-producing status and I think we
should acknowledge that without calling
people racists and xenophobes we should
be able to talk about that economic
anxiety and so somebody like Tommy
Lehren is tapping too into that anxiety
and while she's right that America's
should be colorblind I think she's
actually giving people very upset in the
other direction against the minorities
against the people who won't stand and
in general my
book calls for overcoming political
tribalism we we need to be able to talk
to each other as Americans again and not
just say oh you're the evil ones you
know it used to be that people on the
other side of the political divide we're
just people that we disagreed with now
it's almost like the people who voted
for the other candidate are immoral
they're our enemies they're not even
real Americans anymore and this because
I study really democracies around the
world places like Libya
I mean Libya what's the difference
between Libya and the United States
Libya is a multi-ethnic country to a
hundred forty different people's it's a
failed state it's disintegrated why
because it doesn't have that overarching
strong Libyan identity strong enough to
hold the country together was really a
colonial construction but we do this is
what makes us special our national
identity is different it's again it's in
our Constitution so we all need to try
to live up to the ideals in our
Constitution both sides both you know
the people who are little really anxious
about all these minorities the changing
color of America let's talk about it
you're allowed to be anxious and the
other side should just call them
xenophobic but every generation has seen
a new round of immigrants and we were
always suspicious when the polls first
came in no don't let the polls come in
Italians oh no those are going to be all
criminals
you know the japanese-americans no but
each time we've overcome that initial
fear and xenophobia each time we've
become our better selves and we can't be
the the missing link we can't be the
weak link you have two charts in the
book that I want to put on the screen
the first one is from 1960 and this
shows us foreign-born residents starting
with Italy at one point two million nine
hundred ninety thousand Germans nine
hundred fifty-three thousand Canadians
eight hundred and thirty three thousand
you members of people from the UK and
Poland seven hundred forty-eight
thousand just look at that for a minute
and see how this changes as you put up
in your book a chart from the year 2000
just 40 years later Mexican 7.8 million
Chinese 1.3 Philippines 1.2 India a
million in Cuba almost a million why'd
you do why did you put that in the book
well first of all just because it's true
you know I feel like our politics in
this country are so divided that you
just have people talking to themselves
you know if you agree it's like some
people are just wildly Pro immigration
and they bash the other side and then
the other side is just very fearful of
immigration and they bash the other side
but it is in fact true that the
composition of our immigrants has
changed it used to be mostly from Europe
now they are principally from Latin
America Asia and other parts of the
developing world so there is a change
the Browning of America also the numbers
are much much bigger 7 million compared
to 100,000 and this is something we need
to talk about right now it's we're not
getting anywhere the the tribalism that
has taken over our politics is
preventing us from having conversations
that we need to have about immigration
we can't just have no rules for
immigration I am the child of immigrants
I've written books about how important
immigration is for the strength of this
country and yet of course we need limits
we need rules we need to have a debate
about who can come in what are the
qualifications that's every country has
that and the tribalism that has
paralyzed our country is making it
impossible for us to talk to each other
people should be able to say you know
I'm anxious are these numbers right is
this the way it should be
without instantly being called you know
some terrible name and yet on the other
side people shouldn't just immediately
look at the skin color of who's coming
in and saying oh we got to block those I
mean actually look at these people as
human beings and open your hearts and
and you know we need to get back to
where we we're worried we've been at our
best
speaking of human beings here are two
human beings that you know well and this
is a photograph that you've seen I'm
sure many times from 2011 these are your
daughters Sophia and Lulu when you were
here before they were like 10 and 6 how
old are they now
ah time flies they're 25 and 22 I'm
incredibly proud of them they survived
all my shenanigans and and I'm proud
that they're thoughtful people actually
always trying to bridge differences
where are they now
my oldest daughter graduated from
Harvard and is in her last year at Yale
Law School and she did ROTC at Harvard
so after working for judge Kavanagh in
the DC Circuit next year she will devote
three years to the US military
army that I'm very proud of her
my younger daughter is a senior at
Harvard and she's my free spirit she's
very very smart and who knows what she's
going to do but she still be incredibly
well she's she's kind of a social leader
how did they survive your tiger mom look
well I honestly didn't know how that was
going to go you know suddenly they're
they're teenagers and they're in the
media and I could not be more proud of
them I think this is the strength of
family not just by children but my own
parents who are 82 and still going
strong they supported me they knew I was
being misunderstood and they knew that
really I was just championing in a funny
way
American parenting values you know me
there's all this stuff about sleepovers
and yes we can have little differences
but it's about high expectations let's
you know believe in our children let's
hold them up to a high standard not just
academically but morally so my children
survived amazingly they also had a bunch
of interviews and I did not know what
they would say but they if you you know
you find the clips they were very
generous to me so I got lucky but what
did you learn if you say people
misunderstood you why did they
misunderstand
a lot of people feel comfortable talking
about books without having read them so
the book is actually not a how-to guide
it's really about the change in my own
mentality I started off as a very strict
parent with both kids and I still am
very proud of that but my younger
daughter was very very different and at
13 she rebelled I don't want to play the
violin I don't like this math stuff and
one of the big lessons of the book is
you have to pay attention to the
individual personalities of your child
they're just different American
individualism I've had to learn it the
hard way at the same time my younger
sister got leukemia and had to have a
bone marrow transplant so if you read to
the end of the book you realize that
it's actually a kind of much more
thoughtful book about what is important
in life
how can we raise our children to be you
know yes excellent students if possible
but also citizens and caring people who
have the right values you know and know
what matters my sister made it through
but it's actually the combination of her
horrible illness and just the trauma in
my family watching that I mean she had
very young kids at the time and my
younger daughter rebelling that made me
really rethink what's important in life
one of your daughters I don't remember
which one I read this in an article that
she wrote said that she really feared
your husband more than she feared you
and she didn't want to disappoint him
what was that all about
well the strange thing if you read the
book a lot of people don't get the tone
it's supposed to be a little
tongue-in-cheek
I've always loved books with unreliable
narrators where the narrator is actually
kind of a little bit of a character and
once you see that you realize that the
book is a little goofy I mean they're
all it's almost like a circus there were
times that I was almost very immature as
a mother you know I described myself as
huffing and puffing and steam coming out
of my ears and my younger daughter
compares me to Lord Voldemort and Harry
Potter but my husband wasn't so much
about schoolwork and exams but as the
constitutional law professor he was
always
kind of a big emphasis on serving your
country and high moral standards and
giving back to the community so I think
he was actually a little bit more
judgmental and severe that way and
wonderful result that's probably partly
why my younger daughter decided to -
what she wanted to serve in the military
the combination so after how much of
your own politics do you reveal well I'm
happy to reveal that I'm an independent
I I don't fit in anywhere because I
actually think that America's political
parties now as I try to describe in this
book political drives are all wacko
they're completely off they don't make
sense in a way you know you have these
in the Republican Party you have you
know evangelicals and poor working-class
people with the neo-con
people who wanted to invade Iraq it just
it's it's just sort of almost arbitrary
so for me I just want to choose the
leaders wherever who speak to me who
seem well like JD Vance honest and maybe
don't care what other people are saying
as an immigrants daughter I'm always
going to be somebody that doesn't like
victim blaming that's just the way my
parents raised me take responsibility
don't blame others always start with
yourself but as an immigrants daughter
I'm always going to you know believe
that that's part of the lifeblood of
this country that the people who came
over in waves I tend to always not like
people who scapegoat and target each
other
I feel like often these are
opportunistic politicians who are just
trying to get votes for themselves and I
actually don't think that most Americans
this is what I say in the last chapter I
don't think most Americans like all the
shrill name-calling that we see on cable
news and social media all the targeting
I think people are wary of it and and
really want to change and I think there
will be a change there's a new story
that we have from kV UE in Austin Texas
from 2017 and
you write about this in your book let's
watch this and you can come back and
fill in the blanks despite many Church's
stance against it Santa Muerte is the
fastest growing folk religion in the
world
Jose Marella a pastor with buenas nuevas
Christian Church calls it witchcraft it
is exactly what the Bible calls it is
witchcraft and unfortunately is against
God's Word her followers say anything
they ask for she returns Santa Muerte
has become an icon for drug traffickers
they believe she has a tolerance for
dark deeds a prayer keeps them protected
allowing them to be more bold yes this
isn't one of the most interesting parts
of my book I chapter showing that a lot
of America's elites just miss the group
identities that matter most to people so
many people in America especially
lower-income struggling Americans want
hope and a lot of the progressives on
college campuses I mean they're trying
to do the right thing but they are
constantly trying to expose the American
Dream as a sham and I understand what
that comes from you know we have had a
slowing and upward mobility we do need
to make the American dream real for more
people but they often sort of trash it
and say oh it's all hypocrisy our values
are all hypocrisy that clip shows that
many many poor Mexican Americans who you
know don't have jobs they're not
relating to all this stuff that they
hear in Washington it just seems like a
bunch of elites god knows what they're
doing in Washington and they just find
their own groups that speak to them and
this is very sad I mean this that this
is the the goddess of death operating
offering them hope but they pray they
pray there and people follow just a huge
number of Americans and what they are
hoping for is they are praying in some
ways for prosperity and health and the
prosperity gospel in the United States
another huge movement that I discussed
most of the elites in New York and DC
have never heard of these groups you
know they're more interested in the
activist groups but they don't realize
that even though these activist groups
like Occupy
they're they're coming from a good place
they want to help poor people but they
don't include any poor people they I I
think I think this is partly why wrote
the book there are there's a huge gap
chasm between the haves and have-nots
and or just middle America a lot of the
elites on the coast they're kind of in
their own world again trying to do the
right thing but they don't really know
about the lives and what's meaningful to
so many people whether it's the poor
Latino Americans or its people in
Appalachia or or you know struggling
Americans anywhere for those who have
never seen this this is a little clip
with you and your husband back in 2014
where you wrote a book together one of
the most striking findings we came upon
in our whole research was that Asian
Americans who are doing so well
academically today Asian American
students for example get SAT scores 140
points higher on average than the rest
of the country not a stereotype of fact
but when researchers dug closer they
found that third-generation Asian
Americans that there was no difference
in their academic performance between
them and the rest of the country can you
give us some more on that yes
so I don't know why this is so
controversial I mean there's so much
political correctness now that if you
ever say these people you know if they
change their behavior if they learn to
study this way or they kind of learn
from other groups that are actually
rising you know we hear about the death
of upward mobility all the time and it
is true there are parts of the economy
that are just completely stagnant but
the truth is if you break down the
statistics there are still many actually
poor groups often immigrants from
Nigeria you know from Poland that still
go from nothing rags to riches so we
need to we need to restore upward
mobility in this country I think this is
one of the ways that we can connect the
Heartland back to the coasts right now
it's what I described in political
tribes as we almost have two Americas
who just don't speak to each other so we
can learn from the groups who are often
immigrants who have a lot of strong
parental input very
good work habits a lot of
self-discipline which I think we could
all use a little more of and learn why
some groups are rising when others are
not trans Ave you know convey that
information teach our schools how to do
it also I'm also favoring in the book
ways of having more geographical
mobility you know it used to be that
people from the Midwest where you and I
are from would move to a coast study
their comeback would be very fluid
now the coasts are so expensive Silicon
Valley is impossible nobody can live
there New York City oh my god you have
to be a multimillionaire and education
has gotten so expensive that it's no
longer that channel of mobility that it
was for so many years in this country
and that's what I discussed near the end
of the book these solutions what we need
to do to get back the America it's not
scapegoating minorities it's not
demonizing the people in the other half
of the political spectrum it's really
not it's we only do that because it's
easiest to do that and it feels good to
have an enemy I show all these studies
in the book that humans are tribal we
actually our brains get activated and we
feel pleasure when we target the other
the other enemy and we see them
suffering we actually feel good but we
can overcome this studies show that if
we make an effort it's not our default
mode our default mode is tribalism but
if we make an effort we can overcome
these primal tribal instincts and come
together and that's actually was always
what the American experiment was it was
to be something bigger than our small
individual tribes if I had been in your
classroom since back in 2001 or two at
Yale up to today what would I notice
about the students well I would say that
it's definitely gotten much much more
diverse ethnically and religiously it's
still just you know I don't even know if
it's the national average I mean you
know there's still a lot of
under-representation for example
love latino-americans but there are so
many asian-americans when I was in law
school I was the only Asian American
maybe there was one other person and out
of a class of 200 people now we know we
have many Asian Americans and what we're
actually struggling with right now is
trying to get more economic diversity
that is we don't have that many people
from working-class families and that's I
think part of the problem there there
are groups that are just excluded from
this higher education that is the track
I mean JD Vance writes he was an extreme
exception almost nobody else in his
community made it out of poor Kentucky
Ohio what kind of student was he
excellent excellent
not only incredibly bright bicurious
curious open-minded willing to argue but
in a nice way he would always reach out
I remember to the people of exactly the
opposite political stripe he's you know
an open Republican one of the few yale
law school and yet everybody loved him
because he was willing to talk with
people what are your students think of
our president Yale Law School is not a
fan of President Trump yeah you know
that I mean we're how do they tell you
that well first of all yellow school is
where Hillary Clinton went to school
also like most Ivy League schools law
school is extremely progressive and we
have at Yale Law School many clinics
that are actually bringing lawsuits many
of them incredibly important standing up
just for the rule of law you know day in
court people can disagree about the
merits but we always want to make sure
that the rule of law is in place and I
think they've done a magnificent job I
mean the judiciary is such an important
institution here and you know as long as
we still have our separation of powers
and three branches of government you
might disagree with one branch or this
branch at a certain time but again this
is part of the the magic of the American
Constitution let me go over some
statistics and you get finally from you
what you think of this you say in the
book that 400 there are 400 566
federally recognized Native American
tribes in the United States you say that
from 1999 to 2008 13 of the 783 members
who had been elected you know into
Congress spent only spent more than a
quarter of their life in blue-collar
jobs you say in 50 years 59 million
immigrants have arrived here in the
United States you say there are 65
megachurches and there are 27,000 street
gangs now that's a lot of statistics but
why did you include all those in and
what's the picture you're trying to
paint America is changing and we have a
number of important divides that we need
to work on it doesn't mean that we can't
overcome them we have first this ethnic
change this demographic change that is
very seismic and we need to address it
you know we have much more many more
immigrants than we ever have coming from
different parts of the world we have
tremendous inequality which we've always
had in this country but the magic to
that was we had upward mobility so
Americans have never actually really
minded wealthy people or capitalism you
know unlike the countries of Europe that
have had strong socialist parties but
that's always because people felt that
if they worked hard and saved it just
got a little lucky they could rise or
their children could rise and we need to
get back to that if we don't we see
people moving into these movements you
know mega churches where they're praying
for money I mean that's that's the
principle that if you pray hard enough
God will give you money no there's
nothing wrong with that
but we also don't want it to be a
situation where people feel so hopeless
with the system so unable to get
education that they feel the only thing
they can do is pray for money that's not
what America was about America was
always about the work ethic self
responsibility and the combination of
that so I think that the big picture is
a lot of the so-called elite
I'm not letting them off the hook either
you know they have not only overlooked a
lot of the most important identities
outside America leading to some of our
greatest foreign policy difficult they
have also been a little bit maybe a
little bit high minded a little smug
about all of the less wealthy and less
privileged people in this country making
assumptions not really understanding
them and not seeing what matters to them
and which is why you saw the 2016
election that election swept to power a
president that took everybody back all
the news media nobody called it and by
the way I was I was one of the few
people not surprised by that election
because you know what you just have to
talk to people who are whispering and
and you can see what's going on we're at
a time one last question to you if you
hadn't become a law professor what would
you have done oh my gosh
well you know I'm so interested in when
I was younger I wrote that I was going
to be a diplomat an ambassador I think I
like I'm very interested in tribalism
and groups because I'm troubling myself
but I tend to be an optimist
I like bridging differences so so maybe
going back to what I said I would be
when I was 16 maybe some sort of some
sort of ambassador or diplomat bridging
differences across countries either that
or I don't know the name of the book is
political tribes group instinct and the
fate of Nations our guest has been Amy
Chua thank you very much thank you so
much for having me
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
Q&A org Q&A programs are also available
as c-span podcasts if you enjoyed this
week's Q&A interview with Amy Chua here